oh so your career what else what else is
more important your mental stability
your health
your um contribution to society outside
of a motherhood so so you're 65. okay by
yourself okay your career is more
important yeah I'm a cat mom and I've
got a great career I've made I've made
I've left I've made my marking as well
just like my mom has like just like
because if a man doesn't have kids at 65
the society look at him in any way would
you agree that mental stability is
important but for me if I hit let's say
30 and I have no kids my mental
stability will be very low I'll be
depressed and even though I want to be
this I want to be that I want to have a
career so badly if I don't have kids
like I wouldn't know what to do
completely right